black santas are appearing in u.s disney
parks this season for the first time
this is a page five story
uh without an official statement or fan
for u.s disney parks are including black
santa claus and christmas celebrations
this year for the first time in the
company 66-year theme history at both
disneyland in anaheim and uh
lake buena vista florida a black santa
has been spotted at certain meet and
greets and at after hour christmas
parties a disney spokesperson told cnn
that santa claus is represented in
various ways in local and regional
communities and around the world and in
that spirit santa claus will be
reflected with diversity surrounding
communities at both disneyland resort
and walt disney world resort with you
what's your thoughts on this yeah i'm a
chicago guy
around my neighborhood in chicago
humboldt park west side of chicago
berwin soros technique we always have
black santas we have puerto rican santas
we have mexican santa so i'm not a coast
kid you know i didn't go to disneyland
or disney world growing up so
my first time going to those parks was
when i was in the military station in
southern california went up to
disneyland i actually got recruited into
the insurance industry out of anaheim
yeah but uh you know very good i can't
believe it took this long however for
for dizziness to actually put something
like this together my sister who's a
dance my sister was a dancer she uh she
ballet jazz all that she worked for for
disney
and uh i always was you know big brother
type stuff and so she was a snowflake
during the nutcracker type of dance
people asked me hey which one's your
sister which one's your sister she's one
of the snowflakes right yeah my sister
is the dirty snowflake
you were in the military your sister was
a ballet dancer that's right that wasn't
fun oh yeah all the time
the most men in the dancing business you
know i didn't have to worry about it oh
yeah
i was thinking more like you're i was
thinking more like your platoon mates
man always wanted to go to ballet
bro when the internet first came out i
said cool yeah which was older brother
phil yeah i had my first modeling gig
awesome hey maurice get over here with
this computer's dial up so started you
know slowly yeah yeah come to finish his
modeling a sports bra this goes to what
we're talking about i destroyed i
destroyed the miners
i had a field day with my marines at the
time dude we just talked about this i
left the sidebar away
what what do you do what do you do if
this is a good question
here we go
because dylan uh dylan and uh uh you
know patrick you have to worry about
this stuff yes
so we i i'm entering an age now where my
buddy has has
daughters that are that are now grown
women forget about
and stuff like that and they're posting
things that are just like oh my god
little little justine what this is i
don't know what to do do you like these
they're posting them they post the
thirst don't you dare they like all your
stuff are you supposed to like their
stuff back no they'll find out
matsupala's sister posts something for
clout
you want to give her the clown
if i double tap on instagram my am i
helping or hurting now here's the
problem buddy this is why how i stay
away from all this nonsense i don't
follow anybody's wives i don't follow
anybody's young daughter it's not
happening even if they follow you zero
social equity i don't give a [ __ ]
there's i like very rarely will i follow
someone's i don't need the drama why'd
you double tap on my wife my girlfriend
my daughter like
i don't follow i'm out i i'm in the
minority here i think you don't yeah you
follow everybody's wife you're double
tapping wives or double tapping you
gotta show support if they didn't want
people to see it they wouldn't post it
if they don't if there's a double
standard that was allowed to exist to be
right this subject matter right
yeah double tap everybody else except my
sister anyway what are your thoughts on
santa
black back to back you know maybe
maybe even a jewish santa every once in
a while sprinkle it i think it's great i
think we we've had dude the only thing
we've had in our household is the middle
eastern standard
to me santa claus is from iran you know
or syrian armenians so
you only have to have a certain amount
of qualifications yeah you need to be
fat and you need to be jolly
if you're not eating well yeah you don't
have to have a shitty attitude but this
is a no for you nobody is not free this
is a cnn story okay to me to be honest
with you i don't even know why this is a
story this is not a big deal that's what
it should be what bothers me is the fact
that they want to they want a parade for
it it's like okay you got black santa
yeah all right but it's like we took the
we went ahead and made blacks
if you want a solid santa with a lot of
facial hair go to glendale california
you're going to find a lot of armenians
that are qualified to be santa's there's
guys armenian food is not good for you
okay
it's oily food you're going to get fat
and they got the sickest beers
but there's one thing about armenian
santas they have a temper so if you get
on you ask for too much they're going to
tell you to get the hell out of here
okay i'm not an american santa this is a
middle eastern center standards are
slightly different so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]